♪ (MELANCHOLY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Was the wife you played
kind of an idealization
of the American wife?
There is no such woman.
-Most of them are wretched nags.
-I don't think so.
Yes, I think we all have
our moments.
Laura Petrie broke down
and cried.
She was nasty
and short tempered.
And she was also sweet
and soft.
And she was many things.
Oh, no. I think she was
sort of a strained idealization
of the American woman,
as she thinks she is,
but it had no connection
with reality.
SPEAKER: Mary Tyler Moore
was America's sweetheart.
Hardly anybody knows comedy
like she does.
SPEAKER 2:
She was just masterful,
but she was also
incredibly inventive.
It's just that I couldn't go
to a party
knowing my son was
on the verge of being sick.
MARY TYLER MOORE: Carl Reiner
saw some spark of humor in me,
and he started writing
for me to be funny.
SPEAKER 3: She was on the side
of risk taking.
SPEAKER 4:
Her morphing into Mary Richards
was such a feminist statement.
SPEAKER 5:
The Mary Tyler Moore Show
hired the most women,
and it changed the language
of television.
Women speak differently,
and we have different ideas,
and we have different stories.
May you have
the pleasure and joy
of working
with Mary Tyler Moore.
(APPLAUSE)
SPEAKER 6:
You were kind of locked up.
The image on the screen
never matched the real Mary.
SPEAKER 7: She was no stranger
to adversity.
MARY: I had a miscarriage,
and when I was in the hospital,
they discovered
that I had diabetes.
SPEAKER 8: When Richie died,
that really changed her.
SPEAKER 9: Just because you have
a smile on your face
doesn't mean you're not ready
to go to battle.
I believe in tomorrow.
I believe that things
that are painful
will not be as painful
in some time.
It's not the end of the world
if I'm not perfect.
SPEAKER 10:
Mary spoke to all of us.
Women could have careers,
could stand
on their own two feet.
Mary, we love you very much.
SPEAKER 11:
Her seven Emmy awards,
her three Golden Globe awards,
and her Academy Award nomination
are only the beginning
of the story.
SPEAKER 12: I think
she was meant to spark fire
with a very delicate match.
Women are, or should be,
human beings first,
women second,
wives and mothers third.
It should fall in that order.